[Música]
eu vou começar fazendo três perguntas a
respeito da roupa que vocês estão usando
hoje
se vocês sabem quem fez essa roupa como
ela foi feita né e em que condições e
onde essa roupa foi feita às perguntas
que o que eu estou fazendo são cada vez
mais difíceis de responder e eu
particularmente não sei a origem da
minha roupa né
mas o que eu vou falar aqui de certa
forma relacionar todas essas questões
têm a ver com a minha inquietação com a
falta de respostas e com a percepção de
que certa forma elas fazem parte da
minha vida eu sou professora derrota sou
consumidora
sou uma leitora curiosa e sou filha de
uma costureira que trabalhava em casa e
foi trabalhar na indústria né então a
minha idéia então é através de exemplos
e utilizando problemas no sistema da
moda atual é mostrar como eu percebo a
moda atualmente eu vejo a moda como um
sistema que se auto destruir um né
se a gente pensar que modo implica
mudança é como se a moda não mudasse
mais nada né como se as mudanças que a
moda propõe hoje em dia elas fossem
vazias nós não nos levam um outro lugar
e tudo isso então seria reflexo de um
sistema que chegou no seu limite da
capacidade e efêmera de gerar novidades
atualmente é quase impossível a gente
acompanhar as novidades seja em termos
de informação ou de consumo a gente não
consegue dar conta então eu vou começar
com algumas considerações a respeito da
a finalidade para pensar o esgotamento
da moda enquanto uma promotora de
novidades
então a propor uma alternativa de olhar
num outro sentido para a existência de
moda
quando a gente olha etiqueta da roupa da
gente ela geralmente nos diz onde foi
feita mas ela não se em que condições
ela nos diz a origem da matéria prima do
tecido dos aviamentos da tinta
atualmente todo esse processo
eles ultrapassam as barreiras nacionais
a moda ela mudou muito ao longo do tempo
é como um sistema que possibilita a
existência social e econômica de
modalidades de produção de roupa ela
sofreu com as revoluções com as guerras
a roupa que era feita em casa ou em
costureiras de bairro ou em alfaiates é
aos poucos passa a ser feita em escala
industrial e as formas de produção se
aprimoram o maquinário vai sendo
desenvolvido para cada etapa daquela
costura as roupas prontas e padronizados
então as passam a ser mais comuns e mais
baratas para a gente comprar a minha mãe
trabalhava em casa até os anos 90 depois
então ela possa trabalhar em indústrias
que terceirizavam à parte a etapa de
costura
o que eu percebo hoje então é que a
gente não participa mais da construção
da nossa roupa a gente não sabe a gente
não escolhe mais um tecido a gente não
adapta mais modelos de revistas ou de
uma outra peça que a gente gostava a
gente não faz mais reformas
é muito mais fácil comprar uma outra
peça e descartar aquela né
então a gente não sabe mais quem fez a
nossa roupa e eu lembro que os clientes
da minha mãe não sabiam
então a gente tem muito mais roupa a
gente compra mais a gente usa por menos
tempo as roupas em geral não são feitas
para durar no sentido material e
simbólico também e as costureiras que
faziam toda aquela etapa de corte
costura e modelagem
aos poucos elas vão sendo substituídas
por operadores de máquinas de costura
que passa o dia inteiro fazendo a mesma
etapa no mesmo movimento em algumas
vezes em condições sub-humanas né então
todas as alterações tanto na forma de
fazer quanto na forma de comprar na
forma de se informar sobre moda ela
sustenta o modelo de moda que é efêmero
e normatizador ele normatizou o que ele
vai dizer quando usar como usar
de que jeito combina essas peças
ele vai determinar o como se fosse o
prazo de validade desse
uso ele vai nos dizer inclusive que quem
tem o corpo da vez é pra usar esse tipo
de peça e ele também é efêmero porque
ele vai reverter tudo que é passageiro
tudo que tem um tempo de duração muito
breve e essa é uma das características
mais importantes da moda ela é chamada
de império do efêmero e uma
característica vai promover sempre a
novidade sempre um novo cada vez mais
rápido e interruptamente vou explicar de
uma outra forma esse efeito normatizador
e efêmero
a gente poderia dizer que a primeira
imagem seria a multiplicidade de estilos
padrões peças que a gente tem circulação
hoje em dia todos eles coexistindo ea
segunda imagem seria digamos a tentativa
da moda de normatizar isso a linearmente
né
dentro de um tempo determinar o tempo de
validade desse uso e sempre vai propor
essa substituição ou vai ser um ou em
seu outro
só que o ciclo de vida a da moda ele não
é o mesmo da roupa é o ciclo de vida
roupa é muito mais longo
ele começa muito antes nossa compra e
termina muito depois nosso descarte e
parece muito óbvio a gente pensa nisso
mas a roupa ela tem um antes com durante
eo depois
e não é o mesmo da moda né eu entendo
então que de certa forma a efemeridade
ela se tornou prejudicial para a moda
socialmente e ambientalmente e do ponto
de vista criativo também a mudança que a
moda vende como novidade ela é vazia ela
é muitas vezes monótono
se a gente for observar
eu coloquei algumas imagens de calças de
várias épocas diferentes e poderia ser
uma outra peça de roupa né
a gente pode observar que a calça a data
de muito tempo a gente pode observar
diferenças nas formas na inclusão
exclusão de detalhes nas propriedades
dos tecidos que mudaram nas cores no
formato dela mas a gente também pode
olhar para todas essa diversidade de
coisa sim tem
de que uma peça uma calça que é vendida
hoje como novidade na realidade ela
também é um agregado de peças detalhes
funções de épocas e lugares diferentes
que foram combinadas de um jeito e às
vezes dá um outro nome e chama isso de
novidade né
só que ocorreram tanto os ciclos de
validação dessa moda que esse processo
ele meio que se esgotou
é a quantidade de informação que a gente
tem a tecnologia que a gente tem e à
velocidade com tudo isso com que tudo
isso acontece a moda pode fazer
referência a qualquer tempo né
a criação a ela pode ter é muito difícil
hoje eu determinar a origem de uma
criação ou remeter ela único estilista
há uma única marca desse ponto de vista
a gente pode dizer que praticamente tudo
já foi criado em moda o exemplo de um
exemplo que poderia dar essa
retroalimentação da moda na rapidez com
que ela se retroalimenta é o modelo de
produzir roupa do fast fashion né
aqui há os dados de compra vão gerir as
novas produções não o que é mais vendido
vai ser mais produzido em menos de 20
dias você vai ter uma peça muito
semelhante na rua na loja para comprar a
sua exposição né de vários de diversos
preços dependendo do lugar com uma
pesquisa de mestrado a respeito disso eu
percebi que a cópia ela faz parte do
processo de desenvolvimento de moda e
existe uma carga muito negativo nessa
copa nem todo mundo assumir é essa cópia
mas ela é uma é uma constante no
desenvolvimento de moda e eu não estou
aqui julgando isso né é apenas
comprovando que ela faz parte do sistema
de moda da parte do desenvolvimento de
moda né e o que eu chamo de cópia que é
é um produto ou um detalhe disseminado
em forma de tendência não é o plágio
então mesmo que exista essa carga
negativa o mercado ele acredita
rita nesse sistema efêmero de gerar
novidades é ele acredita nessa forma de
criar moda até como um como uma forma de
não correr riscos e nesse tipo de
indústria o estilista bom é aquele que
produz o que vende mais rápido e que vem
de mais os meus colegas que atuam na
indústria eles até reclamam que o
trabalho deles se resume a fazer um
desenho técnico enquanto preenchem uma
planilha de custos né de um modelo que
viu na internet de uma blogueira por
exemplo só que no entanto esse modelo é
efêmero de adaptações do mesmo que
inclusive possibilita que a gente use
uma roupa muito parecida com as
passarelas das blogueiras por um preço
muito baixo a gente consegue encontrar
ele se utiliza de um termo também
problemático que é democratização da
moda
e ele mostra uma visão bem superficial e
romantizado dessa moda porque ele
sustenta a ideia de que existe uma
participação não é uma consenso digamos
assim uma soberania popular uma escolha
né
só que quem participa da moda quem
compra e quem produz e quem faz
participa e igualmente dessa democracia
a gente for observar os dados de
produção de quanto custa produzir uma
camisa jeans nos estados unidos em
bangladesh e chama a atenção para o
último dado é que o custo da mão de obra
a gente vai perceber que muita diferença
onde leciono por exemplo é esse dado ele
não é do brasil mas ele serve pra pensar
o brasil porque aqui a mão de obra
muitas vezes joga como cara né onde
lecionou por exemplo a gente forma
técnicos e em têxtil e moda ea gente já
ouviu de alguns empresários que a gente
forma muito cacique para pouco índio
porque porque os nossos alunos
usamos eles não têm vontade por exemplo
de ocupar uma vaga de operador de
máquina de costura
mas eu me pergunto que valorizam que
valorização recebe essa profissão para o
aluno que sai de um curso técnico queria
ocupá lá né e quem entra nessa profissão
será que desejam se manter nela os dados
do fast fashion
será que de 1 a 2 por cento do valor de
uma peça vai pra quem produziu né
então nesse sistema o custo baixíssimo
de produção ele só é possível em países
onde o salário mínimo ele fica muito
abaixo das condições mínimas para a
sobrevivência então as pessoas trabalham
de 12 a 14 horas por dia de 7 de 6 a 7
dias por semana pra dar conta de
sobreviver e não sobra espaço pra
educação para lazer e nem pra educar os
próprios filhos
então nesse sistema efêmero onde há
salário diguinho é praticamente inviável
produzir nelton falo do fast fashion
então a gente precisa desconfiar das
condições de trabalho por trás de roupas
muito baratas muitas vezes a gente se
orgulha de comprar uma roupa muito
barato a gente deve desconfiar disso e
só que não pensar que existe exploração
de mão de obra
só em roupas baratas não ó também existe
roupas caras
a gente precisa ainda de informar e
fazer essas perguntas que foram feitas
no começo o conhecimento dos danos é que
eu acredito que vai fazer a gente
ultrapassar nessa vai superar digamos
essa lógica essa lógica que levou a moda
se tornou inclusive a segunda indústria
que mais polui no mundo é que é preciso
dar visibilidade e infrações que nos
tirem da zona de conforto né é
importante então apresentar os problemas
porque dificilmente eles vão se tornar
notícia em revistas de moda na tentativa
então de nomear é um caminho possível
para olhar a moda é e de deus para a
partir daí não partimos da idéia da
efemeridade eu trago um conceito que eu
utilizo de 2014
nas minhas pesquisas e elas têm um um
perfil um pouco filosófico digamos assim
de olhar para a moda é o nome utilizado
é que ele não é mais importante não é
resistência não é o mais importante é
apenas um jogo de palavras de palavras
mas é o entendimento dele que me move
especialmente como professora como
pesquisador e que eu gostaria que mover
se vocês também né
assistência num primeiro momento vende
do som que se que se produza né então
venho de resistência de resistir e
existe na moda é muito difícil porque a
moda tudo dividiu essas formas né
aqui não basta a gente se opor às regras
da moda é muito melhor a gente
desestabilizar expor os problemas da
moda e utilizar a própria moda ea roupa
para isso então resistência é esse
primeiro som presidente resistir à
própria existência dos problemas da moda
já vai se configurar como uma razão para
uma mudança de olhar é todos nós que
participamos diretamente da moda porque
todos nós usamos roupa a gente pode
encontrar linhas de fuga que cria um
outro outro lugar
um outro espaço para moda ocupar a nossa
vida a existência então seria notar que
tipo de existência que a moda tem na
nossa vida hoje
explorando pessoas degradando o meio
ambiente e produzir uma espécie de mesmo
né
a resistência então seria o que dá uma
outra forma de existência para a moda na
nossa vida na academia no design e no
consumo uso na forma de descartar a ela
a boa notícia é que algumas pessoas já
estão percebendo isso né e essas ações
firmes surge em forma de documentário
campanhas de conscientização propagandas
produtos né ações diferentes de
empresários e consumidores
o fashion revolution é um exemplo desse
é uma campanha de conscientização que
convoca a todos então a pensar a
questionar né quem produzir reproduzir
nossas roupas né a por meio de tags uma
data anual não o subtema e coloca você
então como uma voz ativa para pensar
então essa democratização da moda de
forma prática é e citando apenas uma das
possibilidades de se desse ciclo de moda
e utilizando o final do ciclo a gente
pode estabilizar se
de vida breve de um produto de moda
utilizando o final do ciclo para a
criação de novas roupas mostrando a
viabilidade criativa e econômica de se
produzir partindo do final do ciclo é a
que eu trouxe o exemplo da escola onde
eu trabalho né
aqui a idéia então é prolongar a vida
das coisas né e significa o seu uso ea
criatividade então aquela despertada
pelo que existe é uma catalizador para
novas idéias
o escritório é uma outra um outro
exemplo disso que também utiliza o final
do ciclo mas não com a intenção de criar
um novo produto
ele é uma iniciativa de doação de roupas
que qualquer um pode fazer na sua cidade
é ele possibilita a escolha que nem
todos podem fazer da roupa que a gente
usa é muito se é pra gente parece muito
simples que a gente escolhe o que a
gente vai usar né
mas esse tipo de ação ele possibilita
que ao invés de receber uma sacola de
roupas né femininas adulto por exemplo
eu posso escolher o tipo de roupa que eu
vou usar né e eu que todo ano em vez de
entregar eu dou essa pessoa a
oportunidade ela escolher que tipo de
roupa ela vai usar isso parece muito
simples mas apenas reconfigurar a forma
de doha roupa ela modifica o sentido
social de escolha de participação e até
mesmo de cidadania né
o importante é pensar que há outros
caminhos para roupa que a gente não tem
mais vontade essa apresentação
eu lembrei dessa foto e dessa roupa que
utilizava e meu irmão vai matar porque
ele usava mandante
nessa época mas essa roupa é um exemplo
do tipo de roupa que usava quando era
criança que era um era feita muito por
retalho irritar com retalhos de de
clientes da minha mãe
só que isso não era um limitador eu não
achava as minhas roupas feias
elas eram eu gostava disso a gente
ajudava a criar inclusive né e o que o
perfil a ironia do destino que eu
percebo é que diferente de hoje que o
uso roupa padronizada comprada em loja
duas têm iguais né a a minha roupa era
exclusiva do ponto de vista criativo e
sustentável é diferente de hoje
então a resistência é sobreviver no
tempo né
os exemplos que eu trouxe aqui são
apenas algumas das formas da moda
resistir
só que a gente vai criar outros há
outras formas de resistir com base na
nossa consciência dos danos que a moda
tem existem muitos dados para mostrar
que a moda precisa mudar né as mudanças
vazias que a efemeridade traz pra moda
elas permanecem pelo excesso e as
mudanças necessárias são aquelas que vão
a ficar que vão sobreviver em forma de
um sentido compartilhado é importante é
muito importante lembrar que a
sustentabilidade para a moda não pode
ser encarada como uma tendência com uma
coisa momentânea é uma questão de
sobrevivência tanto para nós quanto na
moda né e o que a gente faz com a roupa
é que vai determinar o sentido que a
moda precisa encontrar e nesse sentido a
gente vai fazendo política com a moda é
isso
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]